en el vídeo anterior hablamos de cómo
puede ocurrir la hidrólisis en una
molécula de atp en presencia de agua y
vimos que se puede liberar energía de
uno de los grupos fosforila porque así
esos electrones podrán pasar a un estado
de menor energía y podemos imaginar que
este no era un enlace muy estable porque
estas cargas negativas se quieren alejar
entre ellas entonces una vez que todo
esto pasa a un estado más estable se
libera la energía pero tal vez digan
quiero saber más quiero ver el mecanismo
por el que ocurre la hidrólisis y eso es
lo que veremos en este vídeo empecemos
con nuestra molécula de atp y vamos a
agregar un poco de agua por aquí
h2o aquí tenemos agua un oxígeno con dos
hidrógenos y vamos a poner los dos pares
de electrones libres en el oxígeno
estos son los electrones que se
encuentran en la última capa electrónica
y voy a dibujar otra molécula de agua
por aquí la podemos dibujar de varias
formas ok y vamos a suponer que esta
molécula de agua bueno obviamente una
reacción química no ocurre tan limpia y
ordenadamente como ésta esta es sólo una
forma de mostrar cómo es que puede
ocurrir la reacción si las moléculas
chocan entre ellas de esta forma exacta
entonces aquí tenemos este par de
electrones libres y supongamos que este
par de electrones del oxígeno toman a
este protón de hidrógeno podemos
dibujarlo así así tomamos el hidrógeno y
después los 12 electrones que se
encuentran en este enlace se quedan con
este oxígeno para
bueno podemos ver esto como un par de
electrones libres unidos a ese oxígeno y
con estos dos electrones del oxígeno se
puede formar un enlace con el fósforo
pero el fósforo no puede formar seis
enlaces porque ya tiene cinco y esta es
una situación incómoda pero eso permite
que estos dos electrones se muevan hacia
este oxígeno
de esta forma entonces como nos queda el
resultado de todo lo que acabamos de
hacer voy a dibujar una flecha por aquí
bueno ahora tenemos adenosina de di
fosfato y para que quede claro una forma
en que podemos verlo es que este oxígeno
comparte un par de electrones y además
tiene otro par de electrones libres por
lo que tiene una carga negativa es un
poco más electro negativo que el fósforo
pero esta es la adenosina de de fosfato
ahora este grupo fosforila lo re
dibujaré de este lado
aquí tenemos un doble enlace con un
oxígeno por acá tenemos otro oxígeno
por acá tenemos otro y claro teníamos la
molécula de agua que más bien ahora es
un grupo o h entonces estos dos
electrones formaron un nuevo enlace así
que ahora aquí tenemos el oxígeno y el
hidrógeno y bueno aquí tenemos dos pares
de electrones libres ok y como esta
molécula ganó un protón entonces nos
queda como oxígeno hidrógeno hidrógeno y
ahora el oxígeno solo tiene un par de
electrones libres porque con este par
formó un enlace con ese hidrógeno y el
hidrógeno sin un electrón es simplemente
un protón voy a dibujarlo así para que
puedan ver este par de electrones libres
formó un enlace con este hidrógeno así
que esta es una molécula cargada
positivamente entonces esta es la
reacción por la que ocurre la hidrólisis
del atp y nos quedamos con adp
era una molécula de fosfato y nos
quedamos con una molécula cargada
positivamente este protón forma el ión
hidronew y claro en todo este proceso
estos electrones pasan a un estado de
menor energía porque cuando esto se
rompe se libera energía se libera
y energía
que en la mayoría de los sistemas
biológicos es la razón por la que
necesitamos a las moléculas de atp